- So the guy is
yelling at his dog.
He's like, "What are you doin'?
"Don't bark at that bird,
stop barking at the bird."
And the dog's like,
"Um, I'm a dog,
"and I mean, it's a
bird, it's what I do,
"like what?"
(woman laughs)
- People in LA are so
insane about their dogs.
- And then there's
a bird in the tree,
was like, "Um, hey Dumbo,
"I'm a bird, you're
supposed to bark at me.
"Hello, hello!"
- (laughs) You're so
good at impressions.
(laughs) I just, I could never.
I could never.
- It's just real
life, I love it.
(slow clapping)
- Bravo, bravo.
Absolute bravo.
- Hey, Luke.
- Hey.
You know what,
that was just ama,
the way you told that story,
it was like she was eatin'
out of the palm of your hand.
That was amazing.
- Uh, thank you,
Luke Sado?
From Broken Family, that
show was my childhood!
Holy shit.
- (chuckles) God, you know,
I really enjoyed your
dog walking story.
I hope you don't mind, I was,
I wasn't even
tryin' to eavesdrop,
it was just the way you said it,
it was just like gripping.
It was like a documentary
I was watchin'.
What's your, your name is--
- My name's Gary.
My name's Gary.
You can change it
if you want to.
- No, why would I change it?
Are you a Sea Falcon?
- How the fuck did
you know that, man?
(Luke whistles)
Oh, uh yeah, yeah.
Are you alumni?
- I'm not an
alumni, actually no,
but I banged a waitress
that went there once.
- No!
- That's actually pretty cool.
- Oh god, you're buttin' in.
You're butting in and
uh, but it is cool.
She but in, but
she's actually right,
it is very cool.
- That's really cool.
- Right, how's the
acting going, Gary?
- How did you know
I was an actor?
- Luke, you are like
low-key magical.
- I know, I don't
believe in magic.
Maybe she believes in
magic, which is very stupid,
but I don't believe in magic.
I do believe in
deductive reasoning,
and I deduced that you didn't
just come here from Iowa,
all the way to LA to sell
rocks, you know what I mean?
(laughing)
- Oh, yeah, no, pfft, yeah,
no shit.
- Go get my usual.
- Yes.
- Did you have any
plans this weekend?
- No, I have nothing going on.
- Like a loser?
Okay, well, look, I do
this thing at my house,
it's very casual.
It's a charade night.
Yeah, we get together,
we play games,
but you tell such good stories
that I figure that
you could come in
and kind of like
secretly be my ringer.
- Are you inviting me
to your charades party?
Oh my--
- Okay.
- Yeah
- Okay but calm down,
I love Midwesterners.
I always feel like I
could trust Midwesterners,
and you're a what,
you're a what?
You're a--
- Libra.
- No, Midwesterner.
- Yes, you can trust
people from the Midwest,
but you can trust
me, Luke, 100%.
I am full-on Midwest.
Here, let me get your
number just so I don't--
- Okay, of course I'm not
gonna give you my number,
but I'm gonna give
you my third email,
and that goes right to
my second assistant,
so there you go.
- Awesome.
- Here's your Soul Scrub.
Double honeysuck,
no lemon stage,
add-on buckwheat, pineapple
shavings and aloe mist.
- Double honeysuck my dick.
Double honeysuck my dick.
♪ Area 54
♪ Bright lights
♪ Big city, area 54
♪ Bright lights, big
city number three
- Dude, come on, bro.
Broken Family was
my favorite show.
I grew up watching it.
Luke Sado's like a
brother to me, dude.
- I know, he was a
brother to all of us,
but it's just this is a
huge deal for my career,
all right, like you
can't fuck this up, Rick.
I got a vibe from him that
he might want to like,
mentor me, and take
me under his wing.
- You gotta bring me.
You can't roll solo, dude,
that's just lame and creepy.
- Yeah, it's a weird look.
Okay, but you would
have to promise me
that A, you won't get wasted.
- Nope.
- B, no Snapchatting.
- Of course not.
- And C, most importantly,
do not bring up the autoerotic
asphyxiation scandal
that spiraled him and
forced him into rehab.
It was all over the press.
- Of course not, dude, done.
- Okay, you can go.
- Oh, yes! (snaps)
♪ Broken Family
♪ Putting the pieces
back together again
♪ Ow
♪ Sunday at eight, Luke Sado
(upbeat electronic music)
- Hey, all right, what's up?
Who's this sexy
actor, all right.
- Oh, that's my
best friend, Rick.
He's not an actor.
- It is an honor
to meet you, sir.
- Hey, at ease,
Lieutenant Rick. (laughs)
Anyway, this is my
girlfriend Alyssia.
- Which one is the one you
said is from Shit Town, USA?
- Oh, (laughs)
no, I actually said
Shitville, USA, sweetheart.
That's Gary.
Remember, he's my ringer.
- What's your story?
- Me?
Oh no, I'm just here
for moral support,
and I train Gary
in martial arts.
Yah!
- Oh, god, you know
what, that's so cool.
Gary, I wish when I
first moved out here
that my friends came with me,
'cause it's so tough in
the business, you know?
It's good to have that support.
I mean, I ended up bunking with
Robert Downey Jr. and
Brad Pitt, but uh,
whatever, that's
all in the past.
Anyway, you want a beer, Rick?
- Three, please.
Do you think I could get a
selfie with you real quick?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure.
- Oh, oh, shit, it was on video.
- Oh, yeah.
- Rick, you. (sighs)
- No, it's cool.
(camera clicks)
- Yeah.
Do you think you could
re-post that for me?
- (growling) Rick.
- No, it's okay, chill.
Uh, you know what, yeah.
You know what, I'll re-post it,
and how about I follow you too.
Huh?
I'll follow you on Instagram.
Cool, let's go get you
those three beers, come on.
- Let's do it, woop!
(lazy electronic music)
Uh, Apollo 13.
- [Rick] Apocalypse Now?
- [Gary] Eat: The Movie.
- Eat, Pray, Love.
- Yes, Eat, Pray,
Love, obviously.
- She's good.
- It's not, it was
just really easy.
All right, look, it
doesn't matter, okay.
(claps) Gary, your turn.
The ringer's up, come on.
- [Rick] Get 'em, get 'em.
- Okay.
All right. (clears throat)
Okay, here we go.
- [Luke] All right.
- I get one pass, right?
I'm gonna pass on this one.
(group groans)
Yeah, let me go--
- Oh, come on, you're
not gonna pass.
Would Leo pass?
Leo wouldn't pass.
So what would Leo do?
Come on.
What would Leo do, come
on, what would Leo do?
- [Group] What would Leo do?
What would Leo do?
- Okay, okay.
- All right, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay.
- Gary mode.
Okay.
(Gary squeals)
- Peter Pan.
- [Luke] King Kong.
- [Alyssia] Shrek.
- Oh, uh, Planet of the Apes.
- [Luke] I don't
know, what is that?
- Um, (beeping)
(whimpers)
- Glass slippers.
- Drag.
- Goodfellas.
- (laughs nervously)
Ha, ha, mmm.
- [Luke] Second word.
- Okay, hmm, (grunts)
- [Luke] Gorillas in the Mist.
- Uh, Robocop?
Crispy.
- [Luke] Oh, uh, X-Men.
Oh, what's that movie
with the, Congo, Congo?
(Gary whimpers)
Cymbals?
You're a monkey on acid?
You're on acid?
Acid?
- Mm, pah! Toy Story.
It was Toy Story.
- Toys.
- Oh.
- I didn't want to do it.
I said I didn't want to do it,
that's why I want to pass.
I said it, I said that.
- Okay, well, uh,
yeah, maybe next time
we'll have a pass
rule or something.
- [Rick] That was good.
- No, it was okay,
but, how about Rick?
Rick can get us
back in the game.
Come on, Rick, your turn.
- [Rick] You did a good
try, that was all right.
- It was toys and
shit, you know?
Oh, fuck.
- Woo, uh. (laughs)
Okay.
(gagging and coughing)
- Choke.
Tie?
(gagging)
- Autoerotic asphyxiation!
Shit.
- What the fuck
did you just say?
What did you just fuckin' say?
(glass breaks)
I invite you into my
home for game night,
I invite you to my house,
and that's what you say.
- Guys, guys, it
was Transformers.
- How the fuck was
that Transformers?
- You know what,
I got a good idea,
why don't you
transform into a bird
and fly out of my cool
fuckin' house, huh?
(laughing)
Why don't you do that?
- Um, okay.
Do you want that
bird to drop you off
at one of the, what, 30 rehabs
you had to fuckin' go to?
I think that's what
TMZ said, right, 30?
Is that right?
30!
(determined electronic music)
- No!
You know I can't swim!
(splashing)
I can't swim.
- Hey, now that's good acting.
What is he doing?
You don't belong here.
Hollywood isn't for you, losers.
Pack up and get the fuck out.
(laughing)
- [Rick] You okay?
- Yeah. (gasps)
- (groans) Fuck.
Fuck!
Yeah, all right, you
know what, he fucked up.
Whoop dee doo, man.
He was nervous to be around you.
He's your biggest fan.
We both are, okay?
That's a loyal friend.
He would never sell a
tape of you jerkin' off
with a noose around your neck,
you fuckin' creep, 'cause
he's a real friend.
You should get some,
not like this little dick
brigade you got around you,
or your whore model from Saturn.
- That was really good acting.
(Rick sighs)
- Yep, my phone's done.
- Uh, yeah.
(dripping)
- I wished you would
have just guessed
that it was fuckin'
Transformers.
- What scene in
Transformers was that?
- Dude, it was the
scene at the very end
where the Autobot's hangin'
off the fuckin' thing
by an extension cord?
- Michael Bay wouldn't
have fucking got that.
(sighs) Thanks for
that speech, man.
- [Rick] Love you, buddy.
♪ Broken family
♪ Puttin' the pieces
back together again
♪ Ow
(upbeat electronic music)